okay everyone thanks for coming
yeah first there will be good and then
there will be cake
after that hurtful word okay
yeah my name is Marco I'm from Bremen I
work at the company called loyal ants
back to that later
I'm 42 years old so I guess I found I
may have found the meaning of life well
probably maybe CSS maybe it's something
different I'm a front-end developer I've
been doing that since 2001 and yes I
work at Norland and we are Silver
Sponsor and we hire all that stuff so if
you're interested come visit our website
so why am i doing a talk about grid
layout that's easy because it's awesome
and then some so do you have any
questions no okay um well how did we
build websites in the past here's a
here's a slide which you might be
familiar with what is that frame says
right that those are the good ol frames
I'm proposing we use frames now no i
don't but frames were pretty easy to use
I think and you just head up a frame set
and it loads automatically a
synchronically in the background every
containing element on the website but
yep there were some problems with that
it wasn't really accessible for them so
that was bad and it was bad for search
engines and some other stuff and you
could even include content you don't own
which nowadays would be quite crucial
back in the past and no one really met
took took Mara so um yeah
right so what could that be
tables right the good old tables yep
many many people even maybe in this in
this house or so were were always teach
taught how to create a website and for
many years it's been always table layout
you always do it with tables and yeah of
course it was quite easy because you had
easy aligning and centering and
everything you could Center elements
vertically horizontally however you want
and you could create some pretty
interesting layouts like for example do
stuff like having a circle and aligning
things around it that was all pretty
easy with table but the eventual HTML
looked pretty ugly yeah and that was
what most people would call halo hell
and it was only good for fixed layouts
and so we're living in 2017 and
everything is responsive tables don't
really work on small devices well they
do but they're kind of small right so
then thanks to people so first what what
could that be what would you call that
yes you could call it this hell yeah you
could call it dividers whatever right
that is what most people called CSS
layout in the past yes those came all at
once no matter yeah you had websites
like then Zen garden and you had a list
apart and you had people like Jeff
resentment who all proposed that and and
said well don't use table layout you CSS
for for laying things out and yeah that
worked quite good you had to mess with
things like floats and clearing floats
and which sometimes didn't work like in
ie6 and sometimes you probably remember
websites like position is everything you
had all these crooks that you had to
mess with and there were all kinds of
hacks how to fix these problems and yet
eventually we wound up doing only
display:inline-block and display:block
and and not messing around with clothes
anymore but then in 2013 I was happy to
be at a conference in Vassar and I saw a
talk by by Rachel Andrew and she talked
she talked about the stuff that well was
in the near future
it wasn't really possible at that point
but I was really looking forward to that
and one thing of course was flexbox and
as the name suggests it's really super
flexible and right now I back to now
it's it's green and can I use also
probably everyone in this room if you
mess with fear that has already used
black box is that can I have a hand okay
so that's good but there's only one
problem it's only working in one
direction right you can only choose two
to have it in a row or in a column and
and this sometimes may be a problem so
you have like flex boxes inside flex
boxes and and all that stuff and that
really reminds me of tables inside
tables so in this talk by Rachel Andrew
there was another thing and that was CSS
grid layout if you look at the numbers
well I don't have a cursor right now but
it started in at the end of 2012 and
yeah it's I think it's still it's not
really finished but of course yeah it's
the candidates candidate recommendation
but what happens this month
at March 7 Firefox got green and two
days later chrome got green so in your
brother's right now of course if you
have the developer editions you have had
that before but this is green and
concerning Safari and opera well they
will be when the next version of Java
and yeah arise iOS not yet there no idea
when that will come and interestingly
the part on the on the left is Microsoft
of course and they have been supporting
it a little longer
eventually since version 11 I think
maybe yeah that means the first version
yeah but but you need a prefix for that
and it's only the older version of the
specification but you can propose
there's a website for honor for that
where you can propose that Microsoft put
some more work into it and they are
currently working on it but it will take
some time but hopefully not too too much
time okay so yeah let's code not life
unfortunately but somehow life okay yeah
what do we have here we have yeah simple
simple disk with with tips inside I
think and the dip around it is simply a
display block and so the elements inside
are also blocked so in cases in all
these cases you put elements inside this
is the eventual container will grow or
shrink and yeah that's about it so as I
heard the only thing to do to enable
grid layout is to say display grid well
okay so why why is there no no
difference to the
just lock anyone or any idea well it's
just because the container has no no
explicit height so if you don't mess
with the with the elements inside the
container it will stay the same as this
like block so go there okay
okay that was wrong so that's this play
grid right now and the element around it
has a height 480 pixels so they all
align vertically from bottom to top and
fill up all the space letters there yeah
what we can do also is layout the grid
so we can specify the columns and the
rows
unlike flexbox we can do is both way so
I can say that D I won't have three
columns and each of them have to have a
value of 300 pixels and the right one I
did in 240 pixels and yeah basically the
rows defines the height so this is
hundred 160 pixel and this is 240 pixels
and
I should have married it unless and now
okay so when I when I do it smaller
stays the same
okay what I can also do is no let's
basically the same what I can also do is
is use another thing but I come to that
later so this is just good gap you
always know what to do when when you
have like good systems like 960 grid or
something like that you always have
defined these gotta a part and in CSS
grid layout these are called grid lines
and you can copy it you can define the
width of these grid lines by pixel or by
percentage and that everything you need
to do you know how in these frameworks
you always have to make sure that if
it's the half of margin right or half of
the of the gap and then or margin left
on the other element and that is also
quite a hassle in this case with grid
you always only need to put value there
and it will lay out automatically and of
course in this case I'll make the
smaller the grid size stays the same the
gap size stays the same but the elements
are variable and that's because I am I
used this thing which is a fraction unit
that means I define how many yeah
columns I want to have and I say how
much space they have relative to
relatively to each other so when I have
three values there then each of these
elements will have one-third eventually
of of the space that is there so that
that's about it so if I do that like
this like that then the result is that
you have the width of the container and
then the gaps get reduced by that and
then the space is evenly distributed
yeah
what I can also do let's also another
way like in flexbox with order but I can
say where to certain elements in my grid
start so I can say grid column start
right here and grid road start for point
element I get that on the on a second on
good item - so instead of this it's now
- is now in the first position on left
to right there's also a shortcut for
that which we added some pretty strange
stuff so this item spans across rows not
only across columns and I define the
line the line where it starts and where
it and so it's not from 1 to 2 which
would be quite obvious but now it's 1 to
3 because I always define the start
where where the elements are so and of
course I can do stuff like that so this
this item here this graduate item spans
from this point across two rows and two
columns okay
so
yeah this is quite interesting because
you have this thing called min max which
means you define that columns can have a
minimum size and a maximum size and you
can define it like that so this left
column will always be at least 300 and
no a max to the max of 360 pick 320
pixels and when I am when I grab the
window and make it smaller it shrinks
until it's 40 pixels and it doesn't get
smaller than that but the other items
change so you wonder might wonder what's
with that I just included some
non-breaking spaces so in this case
these two aren't the same so although
they have the same fraction unit then
there's another thing inside the
specification which is repeat and you
can have values one is all the fit and
one is autofill I can't really tell you
the difference there it's quite
confusing but what you do like that and
all of it can be used to have media
queries without media queries so I have
this value of 240 minimum and I have a
maximum of one fraction and I make it
smaller end the items just arranged
inside the container when they have to
be arranged because there's there's not
enough room anymore
depending on my sides of my container so
it's quite nice I don't know if I would
really use it because if sometimes we I
have to middle with it maybe maybe it's
better than media Cruz yeah that's also
another thing that's quite nice about
grid layout you can have named areas and
that's the thing so I created an HTML
where we have a header and a side and
article and the footer and I gave them
the names header sidebar content and
footer and I can actually lay these out
Crichton up the art so I say that I have
two columns right and which I define
here so one column is one fraction and
the other column two fractions or twice
the size of that one and so that means
the head of fans because those two
columns and the sidebar is here and the
content is here quite obvious like okay
that put that's kind of explicit so it
may be nicer to layout things like that
what the HTML here okay the HTML
quite simple huh okay okay yeah some of
you might remember that one that's also
from the days of Zen Gardner and stuff
this is the Holy Grail
where I have a sidebar which has a fixed
size and I have another cipher which has
another fixed size and they will always
stay the same and when I when I make it
smaller only the content really changes
the size and the other thing stays the
same
okay and so far for the code now back
back to the little right
this is a website I've been working on
for the wheeler for the last three years
I think this is the last version of it
and they came up with was quite
interesting choices how to how this
article list has to look yeah what cart
obvious is there are articles inside
that article list but there's also this
thing where where where there since know
what wears wooden shaft with us and
that's not an article so how do I have
to what what do I have to do that this
item has the same size as the articles
yeah I did that before CSS grid layout
and I did something which is which isn't
really nice so don't look look to the
code it's their hidden element which
have a padding top which spans these
even in these items that don't have that
so basically where the text behaves like
the other like the articles inside the
article list but let's just yeah
boilerplate HTML inside that only to
have the effect that every every row has
the same height no matter what's in
there and of course that's for these 100
tools and 300 Joules the same and what
they also wanted to have was yeah that's
a grid but they wanted to have you
having lines but only inside so I did
something very ugly I used outline for
that and of course outline it goes
around everything so in fact I put white
divs on the left side on the right side
on the bottom and on the top and yeah
that's not really nice so eventually
I will propose to our client that we
reuse we do that with great layout
because in grid layout all you have to
do is is have a background for that have
a fixed width for example a FOID and it
will lay out like that because grids
always put the gap inside not on the
outside if you want to have outside you
can use border and whatever of heading
over you want yeah okay there are many
other features in CSS grid layout like
you can align these like in select spots
in most of my examples everything was
stretched but I can all I can say it
starts at the bar top and it starts at
the bottom and I can say these for all
elements individually so I can change
things I can even do something like that
an element inside the grid spans across
another element which is which is at the
bottom you know what I mean so they
overlap like that I have one that goes
there and and that maybe there's a use
case for that I don't know and of course
there are a lot of short hands are most
of the things that I use can be written
in shorthand so that's kind of nice ok
so if you wanted deep does if you want
to dig deeper into a grid layout
actually Rachel andrew has this
wonderful website called grid by example
which lists all these things and she
also has video tutorials about that so
go there and it's quite easy to learn
you take one one afternoon and you're
basically done and ready to go ok and
that's about all what I have for you
are there any questions I'm still here
Yeah right I didn't so far but I think
when browser support raises them there
will be no problem with that
yeah one thing that I think is mostly
you used you would only prove have in
effect if you use these on desktop
devices because grids don't really make
sense or you don't have to really do
much on mobile devices because there's
not not so much base or you can have
items just on top of each other but yes
you can use good layout there too
unfortunately not in iOS so far bottom
yeah we'll come